hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't take the risk now I
want to warn you guys this game is going
to be very dark and very serious it
involves you getting a call from a wrong
number but the person on the other line
is trying to find a suicide prevention
hotline so this game covers very serious
subject matters and I want you guys to
know that before going into it because
in all honesty this game is probably not
going to be what you would call fun it's
going to be an experience it probably
needs to be seen the voice that came
over was fun and charming cool and
alluring fun and charming hello hello
this is No
oh boy you have a limited amount of time
to answer no unfortunately no no oh I
see yes this is clearly a signs I should
not have called it was my mistake I will
hang up now wait wait hold on let's see
just kidding Oh that'd be the worst
thing to say you aren't gonna hurt
yourself are you
why because I'm concerned it's not like
you really know me on a personal level
Oh a person on a suicide hotline
wouldn't know you either no one who
cares about me no one who loves me
I do not know that oh jeez that's not
true you do to me I love you that's
that's not the right thing to say no
please leave your message
hmm oh geez you sure are persistent you
you you ha ha what a funny word actually
wait lol is the correct term for that
isn't it but I'm not lolling on the
floor wait that's not what it means does
it huh let's see it means laugh out loud
right okay well I forgot if I was
laughing out loud I've been drinking so
I can be forgiven and taking pills
they're so stone-cold I'd rather have a
warm slice of apple pie there's an ice
cream place with that name right stone
cold ice cream something doesn't sound
right either way it sounds good but I
don't want something cold I want to be
warm see you are are you in the middle
of nowhere
hey hey you aren't trying to find out
where I am so you can send help nor you
that would be smart
I'm trying to remember my address but
it's not coming to mind 1 2 3 4 5 sounds
good twos my favorite number
everyone knows one's lonely you should
get together with what number do you
think he should get together with I may
be an alpha bill would be better later
like a a seems lonely don't you think
see see once city are you in are you
okay hmm sorry I blacked out for a
moment there what were you saying
gee oh wait I can just roll up too many
texts so much white should change my
background before I die what should be
my last parting message si si why do you
want to die why not I'm tired of being
alone waking up to no one talking to no
one seeing no one I guess I'm talking to
you now but you leave me or die like
everyone else you know never mind the
nightmares de ma de I don't know a party
hmm excuse my can't think of English
words translation hmm I hear Googe
translate is bad have you ever seen that
one video they put words in the language
and then another and another
another comes out garbled like telephone
never played that game before but I
heard of it let me find you the video oh
my god it really goes I I don't think I
have time for this I just picked that
randomly one of the first to show up
just jump to the 49 second mark the song
doesn't start till then discrimination
law might not be Queen from the what
here of lecture night hope nothing bad
happens I'm so out of the loop here I
have no idea what's going on just said
everyone's mad I'm not supposed to talk
about politics mi it's taboo or make bad
first impressions am I making a bad
impression or whatever I'm dying anyway
I see see I want to know about your city
what about it it's like any other city
sort of town might be more accurate or
not towns have close-knit communities
right I've never felt close to anyone
hmm
I've grown close with the space around
me the leaves and Ottomans snows and
runer the melting heat in summer in the
first shoots of spring Flula Borg just
we de su not making sense
let's see what stores or restaurants
were around you hmm
I can't breathe mMmmm can you call the
police rage against the dying of the
light
like I said at the beginning of this
this game is not a fun game this is
about an experience that very few people
go through but people have to go through
I mean even for the people that actually
work the suicide hotline this is the
kind of things that they have to deal
with and be emotionally capable of
handling and it's a tough it's a tough
job so I'm going to try the cool and
alluring route I'm not sure how to go
about this but I don't know what the
difference will be hello this is this is
a suicide hotline yes possibly you have
the wrong number
oh I see yes this is clearly a sign that
I should not have called it was my
mistake I was fairly I see you're gonna
hurt yourself are you why it is not like
you really know me on a personal level
yeah but I want to try it seems like the
difference between the voices is minimal
so this has no one who cares about me no
one who loves me maybe I don't matter
I see call that hotline thing care idea
please leave your message I just don't
have to listen to this again alright I'm
gonna try this again
I just I stumbled over the right answers
trying to be quick about it
there are save options so technically I
could do this quicker I'm just gonna go
back to the first one and try to explore
that to see if there's actually any
fundamental differences but no you do to
me I love you I'm not one for lying I
want to see you man please come see me
mad voice ooh that's quite a leap what
is your name
oh man who are you tell me who you are
this is get some talking I'm yep glad
you think so
would you come see me yeah actually
that's probably a good idea
I'll be waiting or maybe not a good idea
I have no idea oh let me give you the
directions to my house where are you
coming from where there was no option
good alert the police or something you
really came yes question mark
he didn't move 'he's to envelop you you
you hug him back come see okay it leads
you into the room by your hand as you
both settle on the edge of the bed he
doesn't release it this is not okay oh
this is a hundred percent not okay can I
get you anything a bite to eat the glass
to drink what the [ __ ]
oh geez I don't want you to kill
yourself darling as long as you're with
me that thought will be the furthest
thing from my mind very well not sorry
there's so much I want to do with you so
much I want to know about you what the
[ __ ] happened here c-can we do this why
this morning
you are staying no the [ __ ] happened
I'm not comfortable staying over what
the [ __ ] laughter you want to stay I'll
go wherever you want I'll see you
tomorrow
oh boy
what the [ __ ] just happened I have no
idea how to even talk about that I just
don't understand hello let's try this
again I guess try talking over the FIR
phone first yeah it's just that you know
I get it I get a call from a wrong
number I want to make sure you're not
gonna hurt yourself but at the same time
that's pretty unsafe that's fine I would
not want to see me either
thank you for making me feel happy for
her well but I do not want to fake hope
god damn it what the [ __ ] I mean
I am this is so bizarre
like everything about this is so bizarre
I don't even know how to describe what
I'm seeing here I don't even know how to
deal with this I mean I know obviously
it's a game and it's supposed to have
like a branching pathway to the endings
but I've gotten one five and nine it's
just so like taking these down roads
that's like skirting danger for myself
and then danger for this person and this
is weird like how much do you help like
how much do you put yourself in harm's
way to help others that's the most
bizarre thing I've seen I've never had
an experience like this I've never put
I've never been put in these shoes and
I'll see you tomorrow you settle in bed
he curls his arms around your waist and
hold you close his chest is warm against
your back for the first time in a long
while I'm looking forward to tomorrow I
want to spend the whole day with you I
want to make beautiful memories with my
bear lights that was sparkle when times
grow cold and dark light me up macelli I
love you mommy more I love you I love
you Oh mom to seal your hairs are smooth
as silk your smile shines brighter than
every star in the galaxy
you are the living incarnation of the
face looks that can kill not even the
most skilled author could put my
feelings for you into arts
I could go on and on but
your divinity leaves me speechless every
word I say is merely a kind of sand in a
desert love I want you to remember
something the other no matter what you
say no matter what you do I will still
love you forever and always Oh mom to
seal your hands assume okay okay okay oh
I've never felt so creeped out of money
he didn't kill himself but it was built
on a lie so you can't say that was good
and my god what situation did I get
myself into that was not okay call the
suicide hotline though eysan you said
you loved me
thirty's and you're acting like you care
you want me to call the hotline to pawn
me off to someone else no I don't know
how to help you vacay
I will then I would like my privacy no I
don't trust you he would be right not to
trust me
you don't scare me
presses the mouth against yours
no you really aren't scared of me you
win no I'm watching over you until you
come to your senses why do you care
because life is precious precious if I
had your love yeah but I shouldn't dream
too far now
I'll turn in for the night then better
be careful you don't nod off not that I
would complain just don't hold me
responsible for what I do to you or me
Oh mom to seal your hands as smooth as
silk your smile shines brighter than
every star in the galaxy
you are the living in I am I have no
idea what to say about this this is such
a bizarre experience it's just so weird
because it's like it really is that it
lives up to his name it's like don't
take this risk it's it's so weird you
hold yourself accountable for his death
if you if you don't go over to his place
and talk to him and yet going over to
his place you don't know where he's
at in his mind and he could be dangerous
it is a stranger how what what line do
you cross to help a stranger what line
do you like cross to save yourself like
I that is so weird I didn't get all the
endings I need to find if there's like
III need to look up a walkthrough and
see if there's actually like a good
ending out of this so I'll be right back
there's ending number one which was the
first one we got stay with me forever
which we got keep your eye on me
manslaughter oh geez you ran this Oh No
oh if Ida randa's head against the wall
it would have killed him
I shot him in the head bleeding out the
police his risky love unknown that's so
weird
so there's only nine endings and then
some extra things that you can do that's
apparently there are only nine endings
and none of them end well in the
traditional sense except for watching
over him that's so bizarre I don't even
know how to talk about that I I don't
even know what to say about this because
this is obviously not a typical scenario
in a suicide hotline this isn't anywhere
near the norm this is obviously a story
and the character portrayed here isn't
the normal person calling into a suicide
hotline I want to say that obviously
this is a horrifying story we're no good
option seems to be coming out of this
other than putting yourself at risk and
like determining what line do you do you
cross to try to save someone in this
situation but in reality and I want to
make a very distinct difference between
this game and reality suicide is
something that affects everybody's lies
whether it's you directly or someone you
know we all have been touched by it in
one way or another and it's such a
serious subject and I always want to
make sure that it's given the gravity
that it is due and I also want to say we
are doing today the day that this video
is released a charity livestream for the
crisis text line
and if you're watching this in the
future you may still be able to catch it
for cuz it's a 12 hour livestream we're
gonna be going all day and hopefully
provide a day full of fun and laughter
and joy that can kind of juxtapose the
the harrowing feeling of this game here
and also bring light to a lot of
people's lives and give them an
opportunity to reach out and get help if
they need it because that's what the
crisis text line does if it's even if
it's not suicide itself even if you're
in any sort of other crisis you can
reach out to the number and get someone
who is ready and willing to help you and
listen seriously listen and that is
sometimes so key in times like this so I
just obviously want to make the
distinction that this is a game and this
is reality and in reality we need to be
there to help people we need be there
and we need to be there for each other
because I know for a fact in this
community there are thousands of people
who are struggling with depression and
suicidal thoughts every day and I want
you to know that life is worth living
even if those words seem empty to you it
is and there are people that care even
if it seems like you're in the darkest
most isolated of places we really do
care and we really want to be there for
you and there are so many resources that
are there to help so anyway I'll leave
it at that today we are going to be live
streaming you can probably catch the
recording if you get to this video late
but just thank you everybody so much for
watching check the description for
information I'll try to put a link to
the live stream and any other resources
I can so thank you again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye